hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we have some details
regarding guardians of the galaxy 3 so
this information comes from a leak which
has supposedly been confirmed um and
it's basically their observation of the
beverly hills action scene so let's get
into the details and break it down so
they decorated a street in atlanta
country club to look like a beverly
hills neighborhood at christmas it's
some sort of action center night there
was several banged up beverly hills
police cars one was upside down and had
stunt seats to suspend the actors upside
down on the car the time period is
unclear the christmas decorations looked
a vaguely retro moulded plastic sand and
large tinsel snowflakes police cars are
crowned ricks from the 1990s or 2000s
jack's jax's stunt double was there i
just saw him hanging around i don't know
what he's doing in the scene the carson
cruz badge said hot christmas in the
styles of the hot wheels logo and lastly
word on set was kevin bacon is in the
sand so there's a few things to break
down here the first thing is is this
actually for the third guidance of the
galaxy film was it for the christmas
special because i believe james gunn
said both of these were filming back to
back so possibly it could have been
mixed up and it's the christmas special
or it actually is in fact the third
guardians of the galaxy and possibly the
christmas special could end on a
cliffhanger or it will just directly
play straight into the third film
another thing i want to break down is
that apparently kevin bacon is in the
scene now we know in the first guidance
of the galaxy film peter mentioned kevin
bacon is a hero to gamora so peter
possibly meets kevin bacon in the scene
or maybe gamora is out looking for kevin
bacon because to her he is apparently a
hero now there's another scooper about
last month he actually mentioned the
guardians of the galaxy will be a
hollywood at one point and peter will
meet his idol kevin bacon anyway guys
that seems like the third guidance of
the galaxy may be christmas themed and
could be set directly after the
christmas special but anyway apart from
that that's pretty much about it for
this video so if you did enjoy please
like and subscribe and i'll catch you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching